here brian the victim daniel halseth is
the father of one of these teenagers and
police say his 16 year old daughter
and her 18 year old boyfriend are
accused of killing him and then trying
to cover it up
aaron guerrero is one of those teenagers
police arrested him tuesday
in salt lake city and that's where he's
in jail tonight now we are not naming
the 16 year old due to her age
guerrero's arrest report says police
found the body of daniel hulseth almost
fully burned guerrero's parents told
police their son and his girlfriend had
planned
to run away to los angeles together last
year
but when they learned this they and
halseth said the teens could no longer
see each other
the day before the murder more than a
thousand dollars was taken out of
halsey's bank account
an attorney for the guerrero family
spoke with the i-team's vanessa murphy
earlier this week
now that hopefully
they are safe and sound and i mean
they're in
the hands of the authorities i i at this
point but
but at least they're not you know
out there on their own and i mean
they're both pretty young people
now today we're also learning police
found two folding pocket knives in the
home's kitchen that had been cleaned
the cause of death multiple stab wounds
and we also police also saying that
there was a handsaw found in that home
with blood on it
detectives say the teenagers purchased
bleach a saw gloves and other items
at two stores the day that they believe
the murder happened
and they also say that those teenagers
tried to dismember
that body now both teenagers face murder
charges
and here in nevada a teenager 16 and
older is
automatically charged as an adult an
extradition hearing to ship them to las
vegas from utah
not yet set for now i'm david charns 8
news now